the u.s attorney general merrick garland
has announced that the justice
department will launch an investigation
into policing practices in minneapolis
after a former officer was found guilty
of the murder of george floyd
the jury returned a unanimous verdict
against derrick chauvin who will be
sentenced in two months time now there
are hopes that the verdict will spark
real change in policing practices all
over the world and i'm joined now by
martial rig
sister of sean rigg who died in police
custody in brixton
in august 2008 thanks for sparing the
time to speak to us
this afternoon firstly what was your
reaction martial when you heard that
verdict yesterday
well it was the absolute right decision
um
everyone believed their eyes including
the jury
and what we witnessed and last year was
it was a murder
and and so they came to the right
decision
and it will be interesting to see what
the actual
prison sentence will be but just one
police officer going
to prison does not change the
systemic patterns that have been
happening
regarding the use of excessive force
particularly on
black men and and using deadly force
but this is also focused on on the
united kingdom where
deaths have been happening like such as
george floyd
and my brother for for decades in this
country as well where
excessive force has been used prone
restraints
following a mental health crisis and has
used deadly
and the metropolitan police have found
that it's not excessive force how can
that be when somebody has died
so this is a real historical moment
that the world is watching yes just
remind us
martial what happened to your brother
yeah so sean was restrained by four
brixton police officers in august 2008
which is almost 13 years ago he was
restrained in the prone position
where excessive force was placed at the
back of shawn's
neck area and shoulder where there was
deep
bruising that was found in the medical
evidence
and also there was somebody at sean's
feet he was pinned to the ground and the
jury
found that he was in that position for
eight minutes
it was later reconstructed and found to
be
seven minutes when it was a criminal
investigation but seven minutes is
still too long and and that caused
a lack of oxygen to go to sean's brain
which caused an arrhythmia and a cardiac
arrest
there was no drugs or alcohol in sean's
system whatsoever
he was only having a psychotic episode
he was fit and healthy he had no
problems with his heart
he did not have a heart attack in fact
he died
the same way that george floyd died
and many other deaths like christopher
alder roger sylvester
mikey powell kingsley burrell
rashan charles joy gardner there are so
many other deaths adrian mcdonald mark
cole where they have died as a result of
excessive force and prime restraint
and we've also had the angelina review
in 2017
where the government looked at um mental
health and
policing and two and to look at all of
these issues
which found that there were over a
hundred recommendations
and to to this day we still have not all
of those
we've still not had those
recommendations implemented
and it is uh more than a decade uh since
you had to go through this uh this
tragedy um
do you feel any improvements have been
made i know after
shawn's case cctv was put into the back
of police fans for example there was a
great deal of talk about how
those with mental health issues are
being looked after when they go into
custody
do you feel that any changes for the
better were made
well the fact is that the deaths are
actually still happening
we we recently saw the inquest of kevin
clark
while kevin clark also suffered with
mental health was in a crisis
he was restrained by up to nine police
officers
and the use of body-worn cameras showed
that he said that he couldn't breathe on
a number of occasions
and he died on camera and that was
you know years after short ten years i
died
so what actually did change there's so
many other deaths
as well so there are negotiations and
you know the government and the
police and the federation are all um
saying and they are doing reviews
and reviews and more reviews and reports
but there's no real effective change
so what would you like to see yeah what
would you like to see practically
um if you could give a list of things
that you feel need to
change immediately what would be on that
list
well we need to change the inquest
system
because if your loved one dies in police
custody for instance
what families have is an in quest system
which just is not a criminal
jurisdiction and it's just to find out
how that person died
families are not afforded an unlimited
purse as the police receive unlimited
funds from the public first to fund such
investigations
and i'm sure it has cost the public
purse millions
of pounds and and the officers have have
always walked away free we've not
seen a conviction when there has been a
death in custody
when a jury at an inquest has found that
the actions of
officers more than minimally contribute
to their death
now we do know that mental health does
not kill you
but restraint does and so this case
that we've just seen in america is very
important
globally and it also reflects
exactly what needs to happen in the
united kingdom i'd also like to take the
opportunity to send
my solidarity to um george's family
from all of the families in the united
kingdom
um in fact from everybody in the united
kingdom we stand in solidarity
we saw that a pandemic could not stop
the protests after the death of
um george floyd and we have now seen
his murderer convicted that's what we
need to see
so that there is a clear message sent to
police officers
that they are not above the law martial
in the last hour or so we've heard that
the u.s attorney general has launched an
investigation into police tactics in
minneapolis you must welcome that move
absolutely it is the right move
but it's again it's another report it's
another review
and so i do well that i welcome that the
president has
spoken um as well on this issue
and that investigation should be
transparent
and robust and thorough
and um we do need to see justice but
it's the same
as the angelina review we had an
investigation like that
in 2017 we have still not
been afforded the implementations of
those recommendations
there were over a hundred
recommendations and what's changed three
years later
i hope this spread light on that
as well of course of course well uh we
appreciate uh
your time uh marcia rigg sister of sean
rigg uh thank you so much
uh good to get your your thoughts
following uh that uh result yesterday
thank you
thank you for having me